foreign
couldn't be here today
but he sent me a text message last night
and said hey can you ask Nedra about
something in her book
and so I said yeah sure so Alabama do
you want to read Ryan's question but
read it in his voice please I will do my
best
has a chapter in her book about managing
relationships with people who won't
change page 103 the following chapter is
about ending relationships when others
won't change page 114. the question I
have is how do you know whether or not
you need to manage a toxic relationship
or end it all together
hmm I love how Ryan is like citing
chapter and verse of the book of Nedra
when he's asking this question like you
said chapter three verse seven sources
you do talk about dysfunction in your
book it actually starts with uh some
ruminations on dysfunction and I think
quite often that that clinging to any
sort of toxic relationship now it could
be toxic because I'm trying to change
you that makes a relationship toxic or I
could have unreasonable expectations
that can make a relationship talk but
any sort of clinging to a toxic
relationship is almost a recipe for
dysfunction but can we talk a bit about
that because I don't want people to
misunderstand because in your book
you're really clear it's not like well
on page 103 I show you how to change
people and then if they won't change I
show you how to leave them in the
following chapter that's not what we're
getting at at all right
and family relationships I've learned
that most people want to stay in the
relationship even if the relationship is
dysfunctional they are trying to figure
out how do I change this person how do I
change my way of thinking about it and
most often people will choose to stay
when people leave I find that they are
ready they've gotten to a point where
they have reached enough I don't know
what enough is I've heard enough be you
know they called me and asked for one
more thing that's enough they you know
cursed me out at this thing that was
enough I can't but
our enough point is uniquely defined and
we have to be able to live with what
comes after we in those relationships
there are questions from other people
there are changes within other family
relationships there is even a change
within you because that relationship is
now missing and so people make that
decision when they feel like you know
this relationship is at a point that I'm
real I'm willing to deal with all the
other stuff that comes with this
there are times when we may not have to
really we may not have to leave a
relationship for it to change we can
decrease the frequency like you
mentioned you know maybe if we talk to
this person less often we're we're less
impacted by who they are you don't have
to talk to people as much as they want
to talk to you and that can be a savior
for a dysfunctional relationship just
talking to a person less so you figure
out your level of personal care in an
unhealthy relationship but I certainly
don't want to say you know what this is
the issue leave the relationship because
you have to live with how you decide to
be in or not be in relationships
in the chapter that Ryan mentioned
the second one there about
Indian relationships when others won't
change you talk about this phenomenon of
Personality issues and one of them is
chronic gaslighting
also when we could talk about that on
the podcast yes chronic gaslighting when
a person refuses to accept any level of
accountability for what they do they try
to make you believe that certain things
didn't happen they try to make you
believe that things are your fault they
will not own up to anything and that can
be very very problematic in a
relationship and when that happens we
try to seek the validation from the
gaslighter no this really happened right
say it really happened and it's like
they won't validate you because they
don't they don't want to be seen as a
certain type of person or a person
capable of a certain behavior and what
you can do for yourself is believe
yourself know that what happened is real
and this person who did it may not say
okay yes I'm guilty that's really hard
for us because we want that sort of
we want that validation from the person
who harmed us and it's really hard for
us to think of ourselves as bad people
you know you mentioned that we can see
those parts of ourselves mostly on
hindsight not in real time of yesterday
I did this thing to you oh my gosh no I
didn't you know we don't want to see
that part of ourselves it takes a lot of
work to get to a place where you can
accept someone saying something that's
not so nice about your character to you
where you can just listen and not defend
your actions many people are not there
yet you might be
they may not be so you can recognize
gaslighting without saying now you have
to acknowledge that this was gaslighting
it's real because it happened it's not
real because they said it so
wow you make me think about I'm a big
True Crime fan and whenever you watch
interrogations the more desperate the
interrogator is for that confession the
more power the criminal begins to feel
the more relaxed they get and the more
they begin to play mind games where they
can manipulate that person the only way
to get the confession if you're going to
get it is to almost appear nonchalant
towards it like I know you did it I know
what happened
you're gonna tell me or not but whether
you tell me or not I know what happened
and so I don't need you to spell it out
for me in order to know what I'm gonna
do about this and and there's something
that Maps over as well when you're
dealing with that gaslighting experience
you've got to trust your understanding
you've got to trust your experience and
your ability to do what's best for you
even when another person refuses to
validate it yeah did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalists private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free